uh we have a great discussion forum on
reddit you can find it at
davidpakman.com
reddit we are approaching 30 000 of our
viewers and listeners
uh subscribed to the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit a few interesting posts i spotted
this morning uh oklahoma is indeed
trying to return
its two million dollar stockpile of
hydroxychloroquine
how funny and sad is it that nobody
talks about hydroxychloroquine anymore
there was a period of time where
hydroxychloroquine was being touted by
donald trump
by sean hannity by all sorts of random
people who were pretending to know
about coronavirus treatments that had
not yet been peer reviewed and
much like we said at the time it was
something to look into and study and
much like many other possible
coronavirus treatments it turns out it
was not actually
effective at preventing reducing the
severity of
or treating coronavirus and now oklahoma
sitting on two million dollars worth of
pills and they are trying to return them
yes
i i have not forgotten about the
hydroxychloroquine fiasco
another user posting that intellectual
dark web
users followers believe i am now a
member of the intellectual dark web and
indeed there
apparently there's a post on the
intellectual dark web subreddit
which lists me along with
um a whole bunch of people
some of some of whom i don't i don't
actually know um along with sam harris
and jordan peterson and others
as being part of the intellectual dark
web i don't know how my name got on that
list
i also see sam harris's name is on the
list and i thought he turned in his uh
credentials
for the intellectual dark web and said
he was bailing um yeah i don't really
know anything about it i got a bunch of
emails saying david you're now part of
the idw
i've never been asked to join i've never
said anything one way or the other i
don't even know the status of the
intellectual dark web at this point to
be perfectly frank i haven't heard much
about it
for months and months or even more than
a year
so the the status of the idw to me is
unknown
my membership or lack thereof is also
nebulous so i have
nothing to say about it i'm as confused
as others are and
lastly yes the bizarre stories
equivalent to the obama tan suit scandal
about joe biden are starting a bunch of
people
sent me this article that was posted on
foxnews.com
joe biden administration under fire
for removing an oval office statue
of winston churchill um yeah listen
we predicted this we predicted this when
we knew joe biden was going to be the
next president which by the way was in
early november
it wasn't january 19th when some other
people finally realized biden would be
president
or even january 20th um the republican
right wing media apparatus was very
quickly going to go back to all of their
normal tricks talking about the debt and
deficit
talking about how can we afford this how
can we afford that
is climate change overblown and
equivalence to the obama wore a tan suit
at a serious event and that was bad
scandal so no surprise whatsoever
and i do expect it to continue join the
discussion
at davidpakman.com reddit